so continuing our videos on Marvel's
what-if series with Doctor Strange right
around the corner what I wanted to do
here is dip my toe in the water and have
a discussion about what would have
happened if dr. doom became Doctor
Strange now a couple things to bear in
mind here for those of you guys who were
new to Marvel Comics and new to my
channel the what-if line of stories are
publications designed to offer us
alternate reality depictions of events
that is to say you know in this instance
Doctor Doom becoming Doctor Strange
instead of Stephen strange in addition
to this this story was written by Dan
Slott and so like all Dan Slott stories
it makes sense in the beginning and then
it goes off the rails about halfway
through and I don't know what was going
on with Dan Slott when he wrote this if
he was just relatively new I feel like
he was but he went completely off the
reservation about halfway through this
story but what we do here is we pick up
with dr. doom encountering the ancient
one for the very first time now this is
this is actually really kind of cool
because this ties directly into the
history of Doctor Doom and what I mean
is those of you guys who have seen my
series on the books of doom we talked
about his life as a child that he had a
witness's mother's murder that he had
witnessed his father's murder that he
had basically gone to North America
because of his vast intelligence he was
inducted into New York State University
where he met Reed Richards but his
mother's soul had been captured by
Mephisto due to the fact that she had
invoked a pact with the Prince of Lies I
guess or with a demon for the purpose of
granting her the abilities related to
black magic and the result of this was
that her soul was doomed forever to
remain in the clutches of Mephisto and
dr. doom himself had basically spent as
much of his life as he could trying to
find ways to free his mother's soul now
after creating a teleporter that allowed
him to travel to the nether realm in an
attempt to save his mother's life in the
process he had basically destroyed his
face and the result was that in attempt
to pursue a cure for this as well as
gain the power necessary to free his
mother's soul instead of traveling to
the Himalayas and stumbling upon a
temple of monks he instead had traveled
to Tibet and he had stumbled upon the
temple of the ancient one with regards
to the original sorcerer supreme and so
because of this when the ancient one had
basically asked doctor do
why'd he what it was that he was there
for the ancient one also purged or I
guess I scanned the mine in the heart
and soul of Doctor Doom and discovered
that he was basically looking for power
but he wasn't really looking to make the
world a better place he wasn't really
looking to operate outside of himself in
terms of being altruistic instead he
just wanted to amass power and the
result was that the ancient one was
actually pretty hesitant to help Doctor
Doom but the ancient one also realized
that there was a flicker of you know
greatness and Victor Von Doom and the
ancient one believed that he could turn
that flicker into a full-on flame and
make dr. Doom's somebody spectacular so
what happened was he basically took
Victor under his wing and began teaching
him everything he knew the problem with
this was that for Baron Mordo the you
know at that point in time the protege
of the ancient one he viewed dr. doom as
a threat simply because of the fact that
doom was able to learn in days what it
took Baron Mordo to learn in weeks and
months and so because of this victor is
wildly more powerful than Baron Mordo
now much like the neo main Marvel
timeline where Stephen strange and Baron
Mordo had formed a rivalry of sorts
Baron Mordo also tries to attack Victor
Von Doom but what happens is that when
he sees his face he actually discovers
that it is a Doombot now Dan Slott does
not square this circle you know for
those of you guys who don't know Victor
Von Doom did not start creating doombots
really until after he became Victor Von
Doom or at least doombots as we knew
them when he was at you know New York
State University and what I mean here is
that while Doctor Doom was creating
doombots while he was at Empire State
University the issue is that we're not
told how this doo-bot got here we're not
told how it managed to make his way in
here with no one knowing maybe he
teleported it whatever the case may be
but the fact remains that this Doombot
also housed within it a small tube and
within this tube is a basically a bomb
on the subatomic scale that dr. doom
plants in the brain of Baron Mordo
basically stating that if Baron Mordo
kills dr. doom or if dr. doom feels as
though he's being betrayed he can
activate the device and it will kill
Baron Mordo and so one of the
interesting things about this is the
ancient one initially appears to Victor
Von Doom after he makes this threat and
doesn't realize that Victor Von Doom was
telling the truth
instead the ancient one thinks he's
bluffing the entry one thinks that he's
basically lying and so
what happens is shortly after this dr.
doom comes to the realization that the
ancient one could easily be toppled
because the old disk this guy does not
realize the advancement of technology in
relation to what Doom is capable of now
following this particular plan that doom
begins to lay in motion we ultimately
pick up with the arrival of Steven
strange now the arrival of Steven
strange happens exactly the way it did
in Marvel Comics and this is interesting
because Victor Von Doom his timeline
started before Steven strange it is to
say Doom was at school with Reed
Richards Doom experienced his face being
scarred before Steven strange
experienced his car wreck which resulted
in him travelling to the temple of the
ancient one and looking for a cure you
know to basically restore his ability to
use his hands and become a surgeon again
but because of the fact that Doom is a
student of the ancient one when Steven
strange arrives here he's basically met
with Victor Von Doom and when Stephen
strange says that his whole purpose for
being here is to find a cure so that he
can continue to use his hands and to be
a neurosurgeon instead instead of
allowing him to become a part of the of
the mystic Artes Victor Von Doom
actually removes his messed up he
removes his hands and replaces them with
robotic hands basically allowing Steven
strange to go forward able to engage in
the kind of surgery that he's used to
with better precision that he was able
to able to do with with his normal hands
that's messed up I'm just gonna throw it
out there that's that's kind of messed
up it's funny like it's funny to me I
don't know why but that's the end that's
kind of messed up but the fact remains
here that because the ancient one
realizes that dr. doom didn't help
Steven strange when he could have the
ancient one comes to the conclusion that
Doom is not the protege he was looking
for and so the idea of the ancient one
is to basically shew dr. doom out of
there as fast as possible to more or
less help him rescue his mother soul and
then get him away from the temple as
fast as he can and so what happens is
the ancient one
[Music]
I love this the ancient one presents dr.
doom with the eye of agamotto and the
cloak of levitation but but when he
meets him when dr. doom has his ironclad
suit on the ancient one just kind of
freaks out
he's totally surprised by what he sees
because it's crazy and and it is this is
why I love dr. doom you know he's like
it is I like it is uh I I don't know why
that's funny to me but it is but the
fact remains that dr. doom and the
ancient one traveled to the nether realm
in order to confront Mephisto now
because of the fact that dr. doom has
the abilities of the sorcerer supreme
he's wildly powerful but he's not as
powerful as Mephisto so I'm going to
keep in mind here is that a model Comics
Mephisto is for all intents and purposes
a cosmic entity I mean he's an elder God
but he's largely considered to be a
cosmic entity because he's so powerful
he literally uses the energies of the
souls to belong to people that he's
tricked to power himself and the reason
for this is that it keeps him at his at
his absolute peak in terms of his
abilities when he's in the nether realm
now when he leaves the nether realm he
becomes weaker the longer he stays away
but the fact remains here that when dr.
doom arrives alongside the ancient one
he immediately sees that his mother is
still being held captive and races off
to help her and because of this
Mephisto sees the two of them as being
stronger together than they are apart
and as a result of their separation he
turns the sites to the ancient more now
what follows is really just a mishmash
of insanity of the highest level um this
is this is probably some of the craziest
writing that I've ever seen in my life
and I have no idea where Dan Slott went
with this so what happens here is the
ancient one initially is able to take on
the forces of Mephisto but the issue is
that Mephisto because of his extreme
power is able to overcome the ancient
one and actually kills him and because
of this the demon lord Dormammu sees
this as a chance to begin his invasion
of earth due to the fact that Dormammu
was always held at bay by the power of
the ancient one now when it comes to
Dormammu something to bear in mind here
is that Steven strange himself has
admitted that if their mom who were to
rise to full power and invade the planet
Earth there probably be nothing anybody
could do to stop him just because
Dormammu is so wildly
powerful I feel like he's a character we
need to have a discussion on at some
point closer to the release of Doctor
Strange just because I really hope the
movie has a trait has a nod to him or a
tease to him because Dormammu is he is a
villain of the highest order I mean he's
he's well he's wildly powerful he's well
beyond a lot kiss some of the cosmic
entities it's insane how powerful he is
but the fact remains that the ancient
one after having been killed so to speak
by Mephisto re-emerges as I guess in a
spirit form and because of you because
he's in a spirit form he's his powers at
his peak but he can't really interact
directly with Mephisto instead he
basically uses his power to move on to
the afterlife while simultaneously
rescuing the soul of dr. Doom's mother
thereby allowing dr. doom himself to
step into the realm of being the ancient
one and so because of this he basically
leaves
Mephisto behind in the nether realm
travels back to the planet Earth only to
find that Dormammu has begun the process
of invading the planet Earth and so what
happens is Doctor Doom travels God in
heaven Dan Slott dr. dune travels to
meet the Fantastic Four now again this
is this all kind of coincides right with
a current timeline of Doctor Doom in
Marvel Comics during this point in his
publication history anyway it's just
things are happening differently and so
instead of encountering the Fantastic
Four after he became Doctor Doom and
took over Latveria instead he's
reencountering the Fantastic Four after
having become the sorcerer supreme in
addition to this Dan song actually does
a pretty good job maintaining the the
essence of who the Fantastic Four are in
this sense that of course Doctor Doom
shows up and said that he could just
wipe them all out if he wanted to um but
the issue is he needs Reed Richards help
because Reed Richards is the second
smartest person according to dr. doom
and the idea is that he needs an
artifact of this that's long since been
lost in order to successfully defeat
Dormammu and so what he does is he
teleports the Fantastic Four into the
past and has them disguised as pirates
and the idea is to have the Fantastic
Four aboard a ship that currently houses
the obsidian stone of myrrh
which can be used to defeat Dormammu
that is the idea the Dan Slott came up
with and people wonder why spider-man's
being written so bad at the moment but
the fact remains here that dr. doom and
the Fantastic Four are successfully able
to work together in the sense of the
Fantastic Four are able to grasp the the
obsidian stone which is specially
attuned for magical properties which can
which of course you know Doctor Doom can
in turn enhance and then take on the
forces of Dormammu which he's
successfully able to do and the result
of this is that Dormammu is effectively
cast back into the Dark Dimension and
earth is freed of his control the
problem with this is that you know
Doctor Doom seems to succumb to the
power of the obsidian stone and the
sensitive drains the souls of its
wielder and the result of this is that
dr. doom seems to be dead or on the
verge of dying now while he is taken
over to Stephen strange for the purpose
of strange using his his surgical skills
in order to try to save the life of
Victor Von Doom it doesn't seem as if
it's possible and it seems as if Victor
Von Doom is dying but what happens is
doom says that he had planned for this
and the reason why was that when he
first encountered Stephen strange he
sensed that strange had the potential
for incredible magical abilities and so
what he did is he created a safeguard
he created a machine that would allow
him to continue his legacy and what he
does is he basically has the mind of
Stephen strange removed or at least has
his memories removed and overridden with
the memories of Victor Von Doom
basically allowing doom to switch bodies
between who he was and the body of
Stephen strange I don't know if that
makes any sense to you guys um I'll be
honest man the story's batshit crazy
this story's insane uh this is Wow uh I
mean it's fun you know it's fun here's a
fun you know it's the story I enjoyed uh
it is just it's a it's a what-if story
we'll leave it at that anyway guys if
you guys are new here to come to explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button
and you know make sure you guys become
part of the rob for make sure you guys
drop a like if you enjoyed this video
and leave a comment down below and let
what you think um was Dan Slott on
something when he wrote this story but
yeah so what Abby said we're gonna bring
this video to an end good god
and I'll catch you all later peace
[Music]